of the ministerial code relating to a
breach of cabinet confidentiality and
the rules relating to the security of
government business
the Prime Minister has made clear the
importance of maintaining high standards
in public life and their expectation
that ministers should uphold these
standards as set out in the ministerial
code
all ministers are personally responsible
for deciding how to act and conduct
themselves in the light of the code and
for justifying their actions and conduct
to Parliament and the public
however ministers only remain in office
so long as they retain the confidence of
the Prime Minister she is the ultimate
judge of the standards of behavior
expected of a minister and the
appropriate consequences of a breach of
those standards
my right honorable friend has explained
her decision to resign and to be clear
the information that was circulated was
subject to Cabinet confidentiality and
under live discussion within the
government
in light of this it would not be
appropriate to discuss the specifics of
the matter further in the house but the
prime minister is clear that the
security of government business is
Paramount as is cabinet responsibility
the Prime Minister paid tribute to my
right honorable friend's Service as Home
Secretary noting that her time in office
was marked by a steadfast commitment to
keeping the British people safe and
overseeing the largest ever ceremonial
policing operation when thousands of
officers were deployed from forces
across the United Kingdom to ensure the
safety of the royal family for all those
who gathered in mourning for her late
Majesty the queen having accepted my
right honorable friend's resignation the
Prime Minister acted decisively to
appoint my right honorable friend the
member for Whirlwind Hatfield as Home
Secretary yesterday afternoon I hold the
new home secretary in the highest regard
a note that he is already getting on
with the job keeping the people of this
country safe yeah that Cooper yeah thank
you Mr Speaker I noticed there's no Home
Secretary this morning unless the member
for Basset law has been appointed Home
Secretary in the last few hours which to
be honest nothing would surprise us at
the moment because this is total chaos
we've got the third Home Secretary in
seven weeks the cabinet was only
appointed six weeks ago the Home
Secretary has been sacked the chancellor
sacked the chief whip sacked and then
unsacked and the unedifying scenes of
conservative MPS last night fighting
like rats in a sack this is a disgrace
the former home secretary has circulated
a letter and that seems to contradict
what the minister just said because she
said it was a draft or a written
ministerial statement that was due to be
published imminently and had already
been briefed to MPS is that not true can
he explain the answer to that and could
he tell us also what time the Home
Secretary informed the cabinet Secretary
of the breach and whether a check's been
made of whether she sent other documents
through personal emails putting secure
at risk was there a 90-minute route
about policy between the Prime Minister
and the former Home Secretary and given
the huge disagreements we have seen over
the last few weeks between the Home
Secretary and the Prime Minister on
drugs policy on Rwanda on the India
trade deal on seasonal agriculture on
small boats and a bit of tofu thrown in
over the letters for good measure is
there anything that the policy is
actually agreed on in the cabinet on
home Affairs what we know is that the
former home secretary has just been
running her ongoing leadership campaign
whilst the current home secretary is too
busy to come to the house because he's
doing his spreadsheets on the numbers
for whoever he is backing to come next
but who is taking decisions on our
national security not the Prime Minister
not the past or current home secretaries
borders security policing are too
important for this kind of instability
just as people's livelihoods are too
important for the economic instability
that this conservative party has create
dated it is not fair on people and to
quote the former Home Secretary this is
indeed a total Coalition of chaos why
should the country have to put up with
this for a single extra day
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker I'm sure my right
honorable friend will be aware that
breaches of the ministerial code are a
matter for the cabinet office not the
home office and that is why I am here
answering the question today and not to
the Home Secretary
but the Prime Minister took advice
around the cabinet secretary as you saw
from her letter and she is clear that it
is important the ministerial code is
upheld and cabinet responsibility is
respected the Prime Minister expects
ministers to hold the highest standards
and you've seen that act consistently in
this regard
but these were breaches of the code the
Prime Minister expects her ministers to
upsold the ministerial coat as the
public would also rightly expect and she
took the requisite advice from the
cabinet secretary before taking this
decision
and I'm mindful it's not usual policy to
comment in detail on matters like this
Mr Speaker but if it would be helpful
with background and appreciating much of
this is already in the public domain the
documents in question contain draft
government policy which remains subject
to Cabinet committee agreement
having this on a personal email account
and then also sharing outside of
government constituted clear breaches of
the code sections 2.14 and 2.3 if
helpful to look at
the prime minister is clear that the
security of government business is
Paramount as is cabinet responsibility
and ministers must be held to the
highest standards
sir edwardly can the minister assure us
that this resignation was entirely due
to a technical breach of the rules and
there was no policy disagreement between
the Prime Minister and the Home
Secretary because many of us had great
confidence in the former home
secretaries determination to ensure that
we meet our Manifesto commitments and
that we should not replace Mass
migration from Europe with mass
migration the rest of the world so can
the minister assure us that the policy
remains exactly the same as it was under
the previous Home Secretary we will stop
Mass migration or do we can have the box
of conversations going on
I I know but but please it's very
distracting this just does not happen
between back Ventures and the Box can we
just make sure that doesn't happen right
Minister thank you Mr Speaker I thank
the uh honorable member for against
before his for his question
um and I can reassure him that this
government stands firm in tackling
illegal immigration and once again this
is not my policy area I'm sure the news
Home Secretary will will highlight this
but uh I would also uh reassure my my
honorable friend that uh he will have
seen the resignation letter from the
former Home Secretary where she does
outline her reasons and that this was
for a breach of the ministerial code
which is why she took the decision to
resign smps person I'm not looking Mr
Speaker let's clear the idea that this
conservative government has suddenly
Avid followers of the ministerial code
is for the birds what was the real
reason for the home secretary's abrupt
departure and was it the case that she
refused to implement immigration
policies that were aimed at hitting high
growth targets due to her dogmatic views
and speaking of dogmatic views she and
her predecessor both supported the
dangerous and immoral Rwanda policy
lying in the face of their own officials
advice about the human rights
implications will he confirm that the
new home secretary that the old home
secretaries departure marks the end of
that abundant policy and will will it be
consigned to the scrap Heap where it
belongs and can I just end by quoting
Colin your prominent immigration lawyer
noted for his comprehensive analysis of
Home Affairs matters today he posted an
assessment uh called braverman's Legacy
as Home Secretary that simply says
Suella Braverman was Home Secretary for
43 days does he have anything to add to
that
I Thank The Honorable lady for her
question I'm not going to preempt
government policy work is ongoing
looking at immigration as part of the
growth plan but it also would not be
right for me to speculate on private
discussions and that is a matter for the
cabinet and of course their decision to
take on that why we are here today is to
discuss the breaches of the ministerial
code and the reasons for the home
secretary's resignation after the
committee leanders
to speaker now then I think the shadow
Home Secretary makes a really good point
the the member for basketball would make
an excellent Home Secretary but that's
uh that's another conversation look I am
sad to see the uh the previous Home
Secretary uh leave we had a conversation
last week about small boats ethr and the
excellent Rwanda scheme but I'm not
convinced so please convince the
minister the Cabinet Government and and
number 10 were totally behind the
previous Home Secretary
thank you Mr Speaker and I thank my
honorable friend for Ashfield for uh as
ever championing the cause of uh making
sure we have secure borders and I know
himself he is a great Champion for this
and will no doubt continue to uh push
the case for this and this government
has shown that it is committed of course
to making sure that we tackle illegal
immigration and the criminal acts that
are going on in the channel and again
whilst I wouldn't want to preempt the
policies of the new Home Secretary
um I'm sure when he next comes to this
house he will be able to uh give you the
assurance that you seek
This truly is an Okie Cokey cabinet
isn't it in and out but what I want to
ask
us the minister directly is there's a
world of difference between security and
embarrassment for the government so can
he actually tell us the security
classification of the documents he's
referring to and also can you tell us
were there any other ministers are using
personal email accounts in order to
conduct government business
thank you Mr Speaker
um so the The Honorable gentleman I
would say this is not information that
uh I am privy to it is also not
information that should necessarily be
in the public domain either I think it
has also been made very clear from the
statement at the start that we are
dealing with sensitive government
matters and it is important that
sensitive government documents are
therefore kept sensitive this is the
reason the Home Secretary attended her
resignation she recognizes that and that
this breached the ministerial code and
this is why she's resigned as outlined
in her letter Andrew Bridge speaker for
the avoidance of Doubt would the
minister outline to the house the
government's current policy on
immigration and will you tell the house
whether it's actually under review at
the moment
I thank my honorable friend for his
question I would refer him to the
previous answers that we have given
again this is not for me to discuss
policy today as much as the reasons for
the resignation of the Home Secretary
although again I am sure that the new
Home Secretary will come to the house
and I'm sure he will be discussing that
in line with the growth plan and our
commitment to tackle immigration at a
future date Ellie Reeves thank you Mr
Speaker that someone who defended
Dominic Cummings and expressed her
intent to break international law ever
became our home secretary shows how
broken the government is under the
Tories but having a New Home Secretary
doesn't solve the problem this
government is gridlocked endlessly
u-turning and completely failing the
public
isn't it clear that it's only through a
general election that we can again bring
stability and security to our country
thank you Mr Speaker again I would
remind The Honorable lady that we do not
live in a presidential uh system and of
course it is up to this government to
command the confidence of this house
which is the case and it has made been
very clear that we will not be having a
general election but this is not the
business for this house this morning we
are here to discuss the resignation of
the Home Secretary and I think we should
stick to that Mr Speaker rather than
trying to diverge into other areas I
think I'll decide they'll do not Tom
Thumb
my constituents were informed yesterday
that 200 economic migrants will be
accommodated in a hotel in the Town
Center in Ipswich of great customer
taxpayer putting pressure on local
public services and actually also
putting local job separates will the
minister confirmed to me that the new
homosexual prioritize the unsustainable
practice of accommodating illegal
immigrants in hotels and also through
their support behind things like Miranda
scheme when empathy oppose which was
potentially the only way we can nip this
problem
thank you Mr Speaker I Thank The
Honorable member for Ipswich for his
question and I think in terms of
reassurance what I would say is we've
seen the Prime Minister acting very
swiftly to get a new home secretary in
place yesterday afternoon and that is
because this government is committed to
pushing ahead with our agenda and of
course important issues that my
honorable friend has highlighted there
which need attention this is why it is
so important that we do have that
stability and this is why the Prime
Minister took the action that she did
because it's hugely obvious that the
homesick he resigned because it's now
understood in government that
government's immigration policy is a
major block to economic growth and if
that is the case then I welcome the
change and I welcome the new Home
Secretary and we will do a favor Graces
the chamber with his presence when he
reports back to the home office uh when
we look at immigration policy in
relation to economic growth will he
remind the Home Secretary that we need
urgent change in the law relating to
visas for a non-eea Nationals seeking to
work in a fishing industry
Minister thank you Mr Speaker I I Thank
The Honorable gentleman for for his
question
um once again I think it's been made
clear that we should not be responding
to speculation private discussions are
exactly that and what we have come here
to deal with today are the facts and the
facts are the Home Secretary has tended
her resignation for a breach of the
ministerial code and policy issues
aren't something for another time and
not this house today
speaker is very disappointed to see the
previous Home Secretary leave her well
she's a tremendous loss to those of us
who hope that one day just one day this
government might finally get a grip of a
small boats crisis it would be a huge
mistake if this government were to
soften its tough line on preventing
illegal immigrants entering this country
upon their departure and Minister
confirm that the government policy
remains unchanged
thank you Mr Speaker I thank my
honorable friend for his question and uh
whilst I I may already said that I I
cannot uh speak on behalf of other
ministers with this I think you will
have seen from the prime minister's
letter to the Home Secretary where she
was thanked for the the work that she
has done whether this was with the uh
huge policing operation uh for for later
Majesty or whether it is with the other
work that she's been doing and of course
clamping down on illegal immigration
keeping the British people safe and I'm
sure that work will continue
Mr Speaker it's been rightly reported
that a member of the cabinet was
involved in a fraccar last night during
the vote was there a breach of the
ministerial code and will that be
investigated
thank you Mr Speaker I I thank my
honorable friend for his question of
course uh if my honorable friend uh
believes uh such breaches have occurred
then there is a set process for people
to refer that to but I do think that we
shouldn't be commenting on speculation I
think as we see from the the press this
morning there are many stories many uh
things about the lobby last night which
I was in of course and I certainly
didn't see what I believe other people
have been saying they saw so I think
rather than comment on speculation we
should stick to facts and the facts why
we are here today
Kirsten Oswald thank you very much Mr
Speaker it seems to me that there are as
many theories and reasons being given
about the real reason for the departure
of the former Home Secretary as there
are stories about what on Earth went on
and we all saw it with the Fiasco that
this government it was presided over
last night so can we have a bit more
clarity on what has really gone on for
exactly is happening and I noticed that
the minister has been somewhat selective
in who he will answer in terms of
immigration I think it's quite important
that he gives us some clarity Here and
Now on whether he is seriously defending
the important policies of the former
Home Secretary
thank you
thank you Mr Speaker I Thank The
Honorable lady for a question but once
again you know we are not here today to
discuss specific policies but we are
also not here today to discuss um gossip
we are not here to discuss rumors and we
are not here to discuss what people may
think did or didn't go on yesterday and
this is a completely different issue we
are here to discuss the resignation of
the Home Secretary for a breach of the
ministerial code and the Prime Minister
has been very very clear that she
expects the highest standards in
government and all ministers are
expected to adhere to the ministerial
code and when they haven't and they have
done a breach they are expected to
resign and that is what the Home
Secretary has done as outlined in her
letter
Florence Echelon thank you Mr Speaker
the minister and and would have had
other members and writing members talk
about the former home secretary's
comments in terms of seeing refugees fly
away for us as members to talk about
people seeking Refuge people fleeing
from war persecution is deeply beneath
this house and beneath the standards we
should have the form the current
chancellor who as we all know is
probably the Prime Minister has said
that he wants to see a more
compassionate conservative can the
minister outline the new Home Secretary
will be outlining that compassion and
when we are dealing and talking about
people seeking Asylum and refuge in our
country
Minister I Thank The Honorable lady for
her question and again whilst I cannot
discuss policy what I would say is this
government has shown compassion not just
in terms of the aid we give abroad but I
would point to the uh homes for Ukraine
scheme you look at what we've done there
before that with Syria before that with
Afghanistan and this country has a proud
history of welcoming refugees that is
something that will continue that is
something that this government has been
committed to will continue to be
committed to and is something that I am
certainly also committed to
appointing a Home Secretary who lasted
43 days and a chancellor who lasted 38
days is unprecedented and farcical what
does that say about the prime minister's
judgment and fitness office she has no
support anywhere in this house anymore
shouldn't she be following her former
colleagues to the back benches pausing
only to ask for a dissolution of
Parliament
thank you Mr Speaker and I I'd remind my
honorable friend that appointments are a
matter for the Prime Minister the Prime
Minister has outlined what she expects
in terms of conducts of ministers and
when the Prime Minister has changed her
appointment she has done it swiftly and
the Prime Minister has been very clear
on this that she expects us to be
working together towards our growth plan
to deliver for the people of this
country and that is why she has taken
the actions that she has Dave Dugan
thank you Mr Speaker the former Home
Secretary got our jotters because she
was on maneuvers and the cabinet at
large is On Maneuvers to find out who's
going to replace the Prime Minister but
the de facto prime minister the
chancellor didn't want anybody's
Maneuvers competing with his own isn't
that the truth it's nothing to do with
that breach of the code yeah
pleasure
well thank you Mr Speaker I mean I would
say to the uh honorable gentlemen I
think the uh
the the proof here is in the resignation
letter of the Home Secretary herself her
the Home Secretary herself has outlined
the reasons why she has resigned from
her position she's been very clear about
the ministerial code which areas it is
that she has uh breached and of course
uh as we say of other matters
um are to be treated separately but why
we are here today once again is to
discuss why the Home Secretary resigned
we're not here to discuss other matters
that involve internal Party politics
okay green the minister may not want to
discuss immigration policy today but I
hope he will share my deep concern at
the written answer I received on Tuesday
from the home office revealing that
nearly 900 under 16 year old Asylum
seeking children have been accommodated
in hotels and the Chief Inspector for
partners and immigration news report
this week that some of the hotel staff
don't even have DBS clearance will he go
back to the home office immediately
after this question to urge action to
get those children out of those hotels
and into a place of safety thanks
thank you Mr Speaker I I Thank The
Honorable lady for her question and I am
happy to pass it on to the home office
and ask them that question so they can
provide you with that information but of
course we do remain committed uh to
safeguarding Children uh whether that's
children in this country or children
that we have received coming into the
country
when Dave
the minister has referred to the former
home secretary's letter of resignation
but in but led to resignation she said
and I quote exactly but document was a
draft written ministerial statement a
day for publication imminently much of
it had already been briefed to end piece
would you confirm that that is the case
and I suspect it is the case then we all
know full well but the real reason for
her resignation was don't we
Minister thank you Mr Speaker I think I
uh covered this previously but um I'm
happy to repeat for The Honorable
gentleman
um you know having this on a personal
email account and then sharing outside
of the government does constitute a
clear breach of the code and that is
there in section 2.14 it's there in
section 2.3 and if it's helpful again
people may wish to look at this but
again the Prime Minister has been clear
that security of government business is
absolutely Paramount and that is why we
are helping held ministers to the
highest standards and the Home Secretary
attended her resignation
thank you Mr Speaker this is a mess this
is a mess I appreciate the mess has got
a really bad time having to defend this
but can he ask uh can I ask him whether
he has asked other cabinet members
whether they've shared sensitive
documents on their personal emails have
they been asked has that extended to
other platforms like WhatsApp telegram
or signal will will there be a full
check of the former home secretary's
phone to make sure that it's not just
personal email but other social networks
and and communication apps that may have
been used in this because at the moment
the minister is not reassuring this
house nor the public that the security
of our sensitive national uh National
Securities being properly looked after
by this government can he give that
reassurance and if he does not know now
will he come back to this house with a
full disclosure of what apps were used
what documents were shared and whether
every single member of the government
have been checked
thank you Mr Speaker and I agree with my
honorable friend that is very important
that documents are kept secure this is
why it's kept separate from personal
emails and so on and this is something
that ministers are reminded of including
myself as a new Minister
um with the big thick rule book of
course that we we have that we have to
read through but what I would also say
is that you know we've made it clear
where there are breaches there is a
method it for reporting that we would
take advice of course from the cabinet
secretary regarding that and I'm sure
um if there are further breaches that
they will be made aware to members of
this house in future Gibson thank you Mr
Speaker the dogs in the street can see
the chaos at the heart of this
government and the home secretary's
departure the full truth of which we
still don't know even after today is not
even the latest example of the chaos
that we've seen
sense of departure as we Face huge
economic challenges a cost of Tory
crisis we probably have not needed
stronger and more decisive leadership
today than we have since World War II so
can the minister explain to the house if
he thinks the UK has the strong and
decisive leadership that it needs
thank you Mr Speaker I Thank The
Honorable lady for her question and I
absolutely do have that strong and
decisive leadership and it was strong
and decisive leadership uh that received
the resignation of the Home Secretary
and then appointed another Home
Secretary the same afternoon and as the
Prime Minister has been very clear uh
the Prime Minister wants to move forward
she wants to move quickly to deliver for
the people of this country and that is
why appointments have been made and of
course with the breadth of Talent on the
back benches that we currently have
there's a wide pool of talent to choose
from and I'm glad that we're in this
situation rather than having to send our
front bench on training courses as the
opposition have had to do recently ready
Mr Speaker increased immigration would
tackle labor shortages and increase the
tax t ending the hostile environment
would improve vastly government
efficiency so given that drawing the
economy and cutting government spendings
are supposed to be government priorities
when will we hear from the new Home
Secretary on how homeowners home office
policy is going to align with the prime
minister's stated aims
thank you Mr Speaker I mean if increased
immigration is the snp's policy then
that is obviously a a policy for him in
terms of our policies I think we've been
very clear that we want to attract the
brightest and best talent to this
country but at the same time making sure
we have a firm but fair immigration
system and again whilst today is not a
day for policy I am pleased that we have
replaced the Home Secretary swiftly and
we're able to continue the good work
that we're currently doing in these
areas we now come to the next uq in
Duncan Smith
uh Mr Speaker to ask the Secretary of
State
to ask the Secretary of State for
foreign Commonwealth and development
Affairs if you make a statement on the
role of the Chinese Consul General who
it appears now took part in the assault
of Bob Chen
minister
thank you very much indeed Mr Speaker
and I'm very grateful to my local friend
for his question and also deeply aware
of the strength of feeling in this house
and in the other place about the scenes
of violence of the Consulate General of
the People's Republic of China in
Manchester on Sunday afternoon and I'm
very happy to provide an update on our
response you've been kind enough Mr
Speaker to indicate that you might allow
me to speak for a few more minutes a
couple more minutes just to set out the
position as the house will know on
Sunday afternoon officials were in touch
with greater Manchester police regarding
the incident on Monday officials spoke
to the Chinese Embassy to express our
very serious concerns at the reports and
to demand an explanation and fcdo
officials were clear that all diplomats
and cons of Staff based in the UK must
respect UK laws and regulations on
Tuesday I announced in this house that
the foreign secretary had issued a
summons to express his Majesty's
government deep concern at the incident
and to demand an explanation for the
apparent actions of the staff of the
Consulate General following my statement
the Chinese charged Affair attended the
summons at the fcdo in his capacities
acting Ambassador for the avoidance of
any doubt the Chinese Ambassador is
currently out of the UK and therefore it
is standard practice in such
circumstances to summon the childhood
Affair and also if I may be clear
receiving an official summons from the
foreign secretary is not as it has been
described a light wrap on the knuckles
but the delivery of a Stern message well
understood within the context of
diplomatic protocol he discussed me for
senior officials to deliver such
messages these summings are not an
invitation for an ambassador to have an
audience with a foreign secretary or
with ministers in any case given that it
was a shajid affair was doubly
appropriate that it should be delivered
by a senior official in the summons
the official set out that peaceful
protest is a fundamental part of British
society and that everyone in the United
Kingdom has the right to express their
views peacefully without fear of
violence he reiterated our clear
expectation that diplomatic and
consulate staff should conduct
themselves in accordance with UK law
and we have made it absolutely clear
to the Chinese Embassy that the apparent
behavior of constant General officials
during the incident as it appears from
the footage which even now more of which
is coming out as we discuss this is
completely unacceptable
now the independent police investigation
is now on the way greater management has
been clear that there are strands many
strands to what is a complex and
sensitive inquiry and it may take some
time as the foreign secretary have said
we will await the details of the
investigation but in the meantime I've
instructed our ambassador to deliver a
clear message directly to the Ministry
of Foreign Affairs in Beijing about the
depth of concern that the apparent
actions by concert general staff and let
me be clear that if the police
determined that there are grounds to
charge any officials we would expect the
Chinese Consulate to waive immunity for
those officials if they do not then
diplomatic consequences will follow
finally if I may allow me to reiterate
this house the value we place on the
Hong Kong community in the UK when the
national security law was imposed on
Hong Kong in 2020 this government acted
immediately in announcing the scheme for
British national overseas status holders
in their independent and their
dependents since then over a hundred
thousand people and their families have
made the decision to move to the UK to
live work and make this their new home
and I want to put on record here now
again today officially a reaffirmation
of our unwavering support for them and
our commitment to their safety they are
most welcome here recognizing the
interest that this issue has across this
house Mr Speaker the government will
seek to update the house on this matter
next week with your permission
Mr Speaker I'm grateful to you for
granting this uq and I follow from the
uq by my honorable friend I say to my
right normal friend just for the
purposes of the house it's worth
reminding everybody uh what happened at
the Chinese Consulate uh in the grounds
on Sunday an appalling attack took place
on a peaceful protester who was dragged
into the consulate grounds and uh
seriously abused and we saw those
appalling videos of Bob Chen being
dragged into those grounds and abused
and it now appears that the consul
General played a part in that physical
attack
Mr Chan uh is a Hong Kong Refugee who he
have welcomed over here I and others are
working to help those get out of Hong
Kong across the floor we've worked
together and that that Community now
feels very frightened uh by what is
going on in the UK by the Chinese
government's Representatives
and he Mr Chen gave a statement for the
first time to the media yesterday Mr
speaker and it was a very moving
statement he spoke of how badly bruised
and damaged he is and how frightened he
is and his wife and child were in the
room as well at the same time I thought
it was very brave of him because he now
fears being targeted by the Chinese
Communist party here in the United
Kingdom so I say to my right honorable
uh my right honorable friend
that now overnight we discover that the
consul General has himself admitted that
not only did he take part in this attack
but that he was responsible in his own
words for pulling his hair and tearing
his scalp this is the consul General let
alone the others that were there so I
like many others members of ipac and
others within this house have worked
together on helping Hong Kong refugees
and I credit the government in the work
that they have done to get them over
here on the pianos but I now urge the
government to be much much clearer than
just using diplomatic language I urge
the government to make it clear in the
light of this new evidence
it's not just unacceptable
that any consulate individual should
have taken part in anything like this
but that any consulate individual who
has proved to have been one of the
perpetrators of this outrageous and
violent attack on Mr Chen will be made
Persona non-grata immediately and sent
back to China the government has the
Diplomatic power to dismiss them whether
or not there are criminal proceedings
the fact is we do not want them here in
the UK and they must go and I urge my
right normal friend to come to that
dispatch box and show the resolution
that is necessary to send that message
to China despite what others and
officials may say be careful of Tit for
Tat ignore that get to the dispatch box
and simply say they will leave the
United Kingdom any one of them that was
in on that attack is not welcome and the
Ambassador will be informed of that
fourth width
Minister well I thank my right honorable
friend very much indeed for his further
remarks uh we should be absolutely clear
that participating in an assault if that
is what we is determined to have
happened uh uh is completely outside the
expectations of our rule of law that we
would expect if such a thing had taken
place as the question was raised in the
house only two days ago in front of the
British concert in Shanghai we would of
course refer the matter to the local
policing authorities as would have been
expected to have been done in this case
so I take the point the normal gentleman
makes uh very strongly and of course
he's also right to insist as he insisted
in the previous uh question that we
discussed on this that the Diplomatic
Channel and the legal channel are
distinct and I have seen the footage
that he describes and I have to say I
think it looks very black indeed and
daring indeed but there is it a process
that we're going through and we need to
make a factual determination and once
that is done as I have said diplomatic
consequences if it is found to have been
as uh we fear it may be that is to say a
criminal offense of some kind diplomatic
consequences will follow
we now come to the shuttle Minister
Catherine West very much Mr Speaker and
I thank the honorable member for um
chingford Woodford green for bringing
this urgent question and for the
interview which he had with Mr Chen
yesterday and the work that he has done
on this this is yet another complete
failure of the government instead of
bringing a statement to this house which
would be the normal way of carrying on
this is the second urgent question that
members of this house have had to bring
and what is more concerning Mr Speaker
is the outrageous admission of the
Chinese Consul General that he did in
fact assault Hong Kong democracy
protesters in Manchester which he
described as his duty
the government's handling of this has
been a complete mess and the minister
will know that labor has called for the
Chinese ambassador to be summoned to
demand an explanation but in a stunning
abdication of their failure of their
duties an fcdo statement confirmed that
a civil servant held the meeting with
the minister young rather than the
foreign secretary or a responsible
minister
while I have the utmost confidence in
the abilities of their CDO officials to
fulfill their responsibilities there are
moments in foreign policy where only a
minister and an elected Minister will do
sadly Mr Speaker it appears that this
chaotic government has Unleashed upon
the country through its failed economic
agenda and is now hampering Minister's
ability to stand up for the most basic
rights which we hold dear the minister
has the chance to send a clear message
not just to the Chinese government but
to the government in Myanmar and any
other country which might have
repressive regimes and where refugees
fear for their safety in this country he
will know that in on the 12th of May
from this dispatch box
we challenged the government to come
forward with a comprehensive plan for
safety for Hong Kong Nationals and
others so two questions will he now meet
the embassy
without any delay to communicate the
strong message from us as MPS about the
importance of peaceful protests in this
country and on the question of the CCTV
footage is it the case that the greater
Manchester police have not yet received
the footage because the Consular General
is refusing to hand it over what will he
do to tackle this problem
is it possible for him to expel the
individual and then for that individual
to apply to return and that way around
at least we would know that the
government had taken the strongest
action possible thank you Mr Speaker
Minister thank you very much Mr Speaker
and I thank God for her question and of
course she's absolute right to pay
tribute to my relatable friend for his
interview with Mr Chan I think that was
a very important moment and he deserves
congratulations from across this house
for that in terms of what she actually
said however I don't think she can have
listened to what I said and that's a
Pity the Ambassador is not in the United
Kingdom and has not been United Kingdom
since before the beginning of last of
this week and therefore he's not
available for any kind of diplomatic
interaction the shelter fair is in fact
in any case the appropriate person for
this kind of exchange the last time that
an ambassador was summoned to a meeting
with a minister and you the foreign
minister was following the Russian
invasion of Ukraine which gives you a
sense of the way in which the Diplomatic
niceties work out in terms of
CCTV and the greater Manchester police
I'm afraid I can't comment on that since
it's um a matter outside the curvy of
the government but I would certainly
encourage uh if it is the case that the
Chinese concept is not giving up any uh
CCTV it has then I would certainly
encourage them to do so
show the slight committee unless you can
I welcome this EQ by my writable friend
it is quite clear that the house is
unhappy with the course that the
government has taken and I'm afraid I
must challenge my writing with friends
on the comments he has made this morning
it is not apparent involvement there are
no ifs there are no buts the consul
General has not only admitted of my
writable friend said that he's
responsible but he has praised his role
in these actions and said he would do it
again it is a political decision to
expel not a policing decision so can he
please confirm as he suggested from the
dispatch just now that his preference is
to prosecute these individuals and see
them in Bridge prisons and secondly what
are the Diplomatic consequences that he
references is it to expel we need plain
speaking at this time the house is
clearly United in opposition and I urge
the government to listen to it
I thank the chairman of the select
committee and
um she has made clear her view that uh a
crime uh was committed here and uh I
think that is the view that many others
have taken but it is not in fact I think
a determination of fact at the level
that we would need and she may have
missed the portion of what I said
earlier to my honorable friend who put
the question that we recognize the
Diplomatic Channel and the legal channel
are separate but they're not separate as
regards to determination of fact and
that is I think the proper grounds for
us to make a as a government a determine
a determination as regards the uh uh uh
political desire
um we will be regard we will be looking
at the fact situation as it's brought
forward at the options I've said there
will be as you may have missed this too
an update it I would expect to the house
next week as further events uh break uh
play themselves out and we will make a
judgment in due course on that basis
semp Sports person Angela Brawley thank
you Mr
these are serious diplomatic instant and
others have said that the scenes of the
violent clash between pro-democracy
protesters and the officials at the
Chinese Consulate are disturbing and go
directly to the against the tents of
diplomacy freedom of speech and protests
now Bob Chan who has fled from Hong Kong
for his life was pulled through the
gates into the concert and beaten by
staff he was left with cuts and Roses to
his face and a video footage shows here
being pulled by the Chinese Consulate he
has already admitted that this was his
duty now the SMP condemned this violence
against peaceful protesters in the
strongest possible terms and call
foreign investigation if these
individuals responsible for such
violence cannot be criminally prosecuted
due to diplomatic immunity they must be
formally expelled from the UK what
actions will the minister commit to to
take hold of the Consulate General and
take account both in domestic law and
international law
well Mr Speaker I've set out the actions
we're approaching to take at the moment
and of course we recognize and I said in
terms the seriousness of this matter and
of course we also recognize the
seriousness with the house takes this
matter now as to the consul General's
remarks about it being its Duty I think
um they are sufficiently uh absurd not
to require comment from the dispatch box
Tim Morton thank you Mr Speaker and
thank you for the steadfast support that
you've continued to show those that are
sanctioned by China the concert General
seems to have forgotten he was in
Manchester where we allow free speech
and thought he was in lhasa Hong Kong or
xinjiang where peaceful demonstration is
routinely met by violence from the
authorities
this doesn't require clear messages in
due course as the minister has just said
this requires strong action now which
involves chucking out some of these
people and it involves posting
additional police outside every Chinese
government establishment in this country
to make sure that no more peaceful
demonstrators are attacked in this way
because many uyghur families and many
Tibetan families already feel
intimidated now they can be dragged into
Chinese premises and beaten up or worse
Mister uh well I again I thank my
audible friend for this question uh the
point about he's he's right to raise the
contrast between our own rule of law and
the deplorable uh despicable experience
of the uyghurs in that have been muted
out to the uyghurs in xinjiang he will
know that only last week uh uh the U.N
Human Rights Commission debated this
matter on the back of a extraordinarily
damning report by former president
Bachelor of Chile and that is now in the
public domain as regards police support
it was a it was a it was a I think it is
a fact about this that the demonstration
was notified to the greater Manchester
police they were on hand at the time and
so it's not absolutely clear that police
support as such is what is required
there clearly has been some kind of
failure in this case and we need to work
out if there was what it was
com thank you Mr Speaker yesterday I
joined Bob Chan in a press conference in
which he bravely detailed the Overflow
deal in my constituency
in an interview with Sky news reporter
Indie Rashid the Chinese Council General
in Manchester has now confirmed that the
footage did show him destroying banners
and assaulting protester which he argued
was his duty
the higher brass and above the low
attitude of the concert General is
sickening will the government stop
dragging their fears and take immediate
action by declaring the council Journal
persona non gratak
well I think well friends and of course
he too has engaged very closely with Mr
Channel and very very welcome that is
too and I thank him I'm sure from all
everyone around this house we
congratulate him and thank him for his
support on that he has in his question
Revisited questions I've already debated
at some length and announced from the
dispatch box we have put in place a
series of measures which we are going
through now and in due course we will
expect to update the house on progress
in this developing situation Richard
Holden I think that's indeed Mr Speaker
and I'd like to thank you sir for your
continued efforts in this direction and
to hold the Chinese to account and help
us do so in this house and but there is
uh the minister just ask answer a
question quickly about there's a another
protest this weekend in Manchester
um will uh has the minister contacted uh
greater Manchester police already to
ensure that those protesters who are
there
um can have the protection of Greater
Manchester police which they clearly
haven't had to date
uh well again I thank God gentleman for
his question I personally wasn't aware
of the uh uh further demonstrations uh
the house has now been made aware of
them I will ensure that uh officials uh
make some notification this is a home
office matter so it will go through the
home office and of course even within
the home office uh network of
relationships our police are independent
of government rightly so for the best
route of law reasons and so we will
respect that I'm not sure yet that what
happened here necessarily was a failure
of policing in this case it certainly
appears that way and we would expect the
great Manchester police to be able to do
whatever they can next time
Mr Speaker frankly this is now just
ridiculous and I hope that the minister
can see the force of the will of the
house and I hope that helps him in what
he needs to do next article 41 of the
Vienna convention for diplomatic
relations says that diplomats need to
respect the law and regulations of the
receiving State and article 9 says that
the receiving state has the right to
declare that person for so no longer at
any time with no explanation the CPS
then says that that is done when the
police have sufficient evidence to
justify Court proceedings now given the
video given the admission the lack of
action by the government is frankly
laughable at this point this is now a
political decision can he explain why he
is not making them persona non grata now
Minister the The Honorable lady uh
quotes the um convention and it's very
interesting but she skated over the key
phrase which was when the police have
sufficient evidence and we're not in
that position yet and when they are as I
have assured the house there will be
consequences if that evidence proves to
be dispositive
thank you Mr Speaker my my right or
little friend is a diplomat I understand
that but does he not understand does he
not understand that if this assault took
place on the streets of this country the
individuals responsible will be in
prison cells and before magistrates
therefore it's very simple every single
day that those responsible remain on
these Shores is a disgrace and a stain
on our society so can we not take the
decision now yep to encourage my
honorable friends and his colleagues to
expel the people responsible today yeah
Lester
of course the house has a very strong
view on this and I fully recognize it
but of course if this if if this if this
apparent offense had taken place
Elsewhere on the streets of the United
Kingdom it would be subject to the same
kind of police investigation and
determination and potentially a
prosecution and a prosecution
potentially as a result
Chris Brown thank you Mr Speaker I
welcome the minister to his post because
I know him to be a decent intelligent
and honorable man
um but he talks of diplomatic niceties
the time for diplomatic niceties is long
long past do you think the Chinese
government cares about diplomatic
niceties of course what the minister
should be doing is